je suis venu vous demander de faire le
bon choix pour la france
certains ont voulu dénier au président
de la république le droit de s'exprimer
curieuse république que celles qui
seraient présidés par un muet
le président de la république n'est pas
un partisan
il n'est pas un cette partie mais il ne
peut pas rester non plus indifférent au
sort de la france
il est à la fois arbitres et responsable
sa circonscription c'est la france mais
messieurs bonsoir le moment venu je
dirais où est le bon choix pour la
france la phrase est de valéry giscard
d'estaing est là presque un an
maintenant
le chef de l'état l'avait prononcée à
ploërmel c'est donc aujourd'hui que le
preneur public a choisi de dire aux
français ce qu'était la nature de son
engagement pour les prochaines
législatives et vers quelle direction
ils souhaitaient que l'opinion s'engage
il l'a fait à verdun sur le doubs petite
commune de 12 cents habitants et vous
avez pu entendre tout à l'heure en
direct sur cette chaîne le discours du
président un discours dont nous avons
extrait ce premier passage sur le
redressement économique
écoutons le penser la situation d'une
personne tombée à la mer et qui nagent
qui nagent à contre courant pour
regagner la rive le courant est puissant
mais à force de nager elle s'est
rapprochée du rivage ailier presse elle
va le toucher
alors une voix vient lui conseiller à
l'oreille
pourquoi te donner tant de peine
tu commences à être fatigué tu n'as qu'à
te laisser porter par le courant
elle hésite c'est bien en temps pourquoi
ne pas se laisser aller
mais quand on se laisse emporter par le
courant
on se noie ouais
oui il faut achever le redressement de
notre économie
l'autre voie
l application du programme commun je
vous ai parlé du programme commun en
1974 pendant la campagne présidentielle
et vous m'avez donné raison mon jugement
n'a pas changé et il n'est pas lié aux
prochaines élections j'ai le devoir de
vous redire ce que j'en pense parce
qu'il ne s'agit pas pour moi d'arguments
électoraux mais du sort de l'économie
française l'application en france d'un
programme d'aspiration collectiviste
plongerait la france dans le désordre
économique
vous pouvez choisir l'application du
programme commun c'est votre droit mais
si vous le choisissez
il sera appliqué ne croyait pas que le
président de la république est dans la
constitution les moyens de s'y opposer
et j'aurais manqué à mon devoir
si je ne vous avais pas mises en garde
et deux alliés deux alliances se
présente à vous
lune l alliance de la majorité actuelle
elle a démontré qu'elle pouvait
fonctionner malgré des tiraillements
regrettable notre alliance et celles qui
proposent le programme commun les partis
qui la composent se sont apparemment
déchiré depuis six mois
aujourd'hui voici qu'ils naviguent à
nouveau leur intention de gouverner
ensemble
quelle est la vérité l'équivoque sur les
alliances ne peut pas être accepté
car elle dissimule un débat de fond sur
lequel l'électeur a le droit d'être
informés au moment de choisir
il ya en effet deux questions
fondamentales y aura-t-il ou non une
participation communistes au
gouvernement
le gouvernement appliquera tilt ou non
le programme commun le choix de
l'alliance pour gouverner ne peut pas
être renvoyé au lendemain des élections
ce serait retombé dans les mares
sondages aidant les interminable crise
politique que les français condamnent
est sans appel
quand il en était à dix les témoins
humilié vous avez droit à une réponse
claire sur un point qui engagent notre
stabilité politique avec quels
partenaires
chacune des grandes formations
politiques s'engagent stèle à gouverner
c'est donc l'un des passages que l'on
retiendra de ce discours de verdun sur
le doubs point final d'un voyage de deux
jours en bourgogne la porte était propos
et qui sera forcément le reste de la
journée
montceau les mines où par exemple
présent un public avait prononcé un
plaidoyer pour un essor industriel
rigoureux ou bien bonne ou clos vougeot
ouvert ajouté restant avait été fait
chevalier du tad
revenons donc à la suite de ce discours
que je vous propose de résumer dans une
coop un cadran et louis quatre grands
thèmes premier thème il faut achever
notre redressement économique et ce
thème correspond à l'image de tout à
l'heure et la personne qui est emporté
par le courant
deuxième thème il faut que la france
puisse être gouverné à ce thème
correspond le passage que le ou non
d'entendre tout de suite en particulier
sur les alliances les deux grandes
alliances
troisième thème il faut avancer vers
l'unité et la justice et développement
ce thème le président de la république
dresse le bilan de son action depuis
trois ans et demi il évoque le programme
de blois et puis il fixe trois objectifs
le premier c'est rendre les français
propriétaires de la france mais il
précise les rendre propriétaires
individuels de la france
c'est de façon très concrète
propriétaire de son logement est
propriétaire de son outil de travail
deuxième objectif répondre aux
aspirations de la jeunesse et troisième
objectif la qualité de la vie
et puis le président la république
développera un dernier thème assurer le
rôle international de la france mais
auparavant il développe également le
thème de l'unité qu'il traite aussi de
façon imagée nous n'entendrons et avant
de conclure il évoque un souvenir
personnel
le président d'un public évoque un
souvenir personnel c'était en 1940 il
avait 13 ans il était le témoin d'un des
bacs
si avant le début du match l'équipe de
france coupe en deux et on vient aux
injures
croyez vous que la france puisse gagner
l'unité est la condition du rayonnement
de la france notre pays a soif de vérité
de simplicité est unités j'agis
obstinément pour l'unité venaissin est
répandue depuis trois ans et demi aux
critiques c'est aux attaques et c'est
pourquoi et c'est pourquoi je tends la
main sont menacés à tous les dirigeants
politiques avec obstination
je continuerai mes efforts pour étant je
dis bien étendre la majorité soyons
clairs car on empoisonne parfois le
choix des français par des rumeurs il ne
s'agit de la part d'aucune manoeuvres
obscures ou de combinaisons machiavelli
mais de la recherche patiente des
conditions qui permettront d'associer un
nombre croissant de français à l'oeuvre
commune
quand j'avais 13 ans j'ai insisté on au
vert à la débâcle de l'armée française
pour les garçons de mon âge
avant la guerre l'armée française était
une chose impressionnante et puissante
et nous l'avons vu arriver en miettes
sur la petite route près du village où
j'irai voter en mars comme simple
citoyen nous interrogeons les soldats
pour essayer de comprendre que s'est il
passé
la réponse nous venait toujours la mer
nous avons été trompés on nous a trompés
j'entends encore à 40 ans d'intervalle
cette réponse et je me suis dit que s'il
exerçait un jour des responsabilités
je ne permettrai jamais que les français
puissent dire on nous a trompés a
finalement la nuit mais non on a
découvert deux personnages qui voyagent
palestin ce soir l'arbitré le
responsable oui d'ailleurs sont les deux
deux aspects du président de la
république l'arbitré chef de l'état le
responsable c'est celui qui prend des
décisions sa cible et le chef de
l'exécutif est l'inspirateur de la
majorité est enfin temps qui vous a
surpris
non il n'était pas surprenant mais si
vous allez au fond il était une synthèse
de deux choses comme il était très grave
très solennelle très appuyé à ceylan
délibérément s'était alors là tout à
fait tout droit l'héritage gaullien et
puis il y avait eu l'apport giscardien
alors on sent très bien qu'une question
de style aussi maintenant par exemple le
goût pour les fables pour les images
qu'on retrouve de plus en plus dans ses
discours
vous avez évoqué le général justement
dont il fit engagé en f1 s'est engagée
déjà assez loin plus loin qu'on le
pensait peut-être a coûté cette fois-ci
oui c'est vraiment le discours du bon
choix entre guillemets fin de son choix
alors là dessus c'est tout à fait clair
je dirais que c'est un double engagement
d'abord ce qui concerne le président
lui-même c'est véritablement un
engagement total sur le plan politique
et là il indique que aussi nettement
qu'il était possible de faire
je dirais qu'à mes yeux il indique aussi
nettement que pouvaient le faire général
de gaulle où georges pompidou quand il
était président de la république
en même temps c'est l'engagement des
français alors là je crois que cosmo le
point fort dans son raisonnement parce
qu'ils étaient plus frappant pour les
gens c'est quand il a dit en somme aux
français je vous mets devant vos
responsabilités si la gauche remporte l
application programme ce n'est pas moi
le président a un public qui l'en
empêcherait moi je trouve que c'est un
mauvais programme et donc si vous votez
comme ça il y aura un mauvais programme
et vous en serez responsable au fond là
vraiment c'était je prends mes
responsabilités en vous le disant mais
vous prenez les vôtres en votant et puis
ensuite eh bah ça s'applique selon la
démocratie alors deuxième phase de
l'engagement c'est quand même l'appel à
l'unité tous les français oui alors là
je dirais l'aspect du président de la
république chef de l'état qui était
clair quand il parlait de la france qui
était clair même je dirais
à propos aussi des problèmes de la
majorité et puis qui correspondait à sa
grande idée qui est que la france ne
doit pas de couper en deux alors là on
leur envoyait tout le temps parce que je
suis maintenant sur la majorité d'abord
sur les deux grands blocs sur la
majorité théoriquement si vous voulez
pour le rpr puisqu'au fond c'est sur une
polaire terriens c'est important pour le
rpr à mon avis il doit y avoir que des
sujets de satisfaction
d'abord parce que le président a dit
tout à fait clairement il ya deux
familles dans la majorité famille
libérale et amis gaullistes mais que
c'est de famille il n'a marqué aucune
préférence pour l'un ou l'autre on a on
a bien boosté tout a fait d hiver
d'autre part qu' il a bien dit qu'il
n'était en aucun cas question de
renversements d'alliances et de séparer
une major une famille de l'autre il ya
quand même parler des conventions
nouvelles il a dit qu'il était possible
qu'il était souhaitable même et ça on
retrouve sa dignité d'élargir à partir
des bases de cette majorité donc ciblé
ça aussi c'est pour le rpm satisfaction
bon autres satisfactions tout simplement
le degré de son engagement puisque c'est
ce que le rpr lui avait toujours demandé
alors maintenant pour la gauche la
gauche qui l'a durement pour l'argent ni
machinerie pour la gauche il s'est
comporté réellement de ce point de vue
comme l'inspirateur de ceux qui
combattent la gauche il l'a fait tout à
fait nettement
il l'a fait en expliquant durement que
le programme économique de la gauche
était à ses yeux il employer le mot
démagogique et l'a dit très très
nettement va là aussi c'est les formes
qui prenait les fables qui racontait
c'est tout à fait clair
bon et puis d'autre part il a posé des
problèmes politiques
et quand il disait est ce que les
communistes ne participerons
gouvernement ou est-ce qu'il n'y
participeront pas et quand il disait à
l'intention des socialistes une des
quatre familles ne peut pas gouverner
seul sous-entendu il n'est pas question
qu'ils aient un gouvernement socialiste
homogène parce qu'on ne garde pas même
avec 30 % si vous voulez c'était c'était
vraiment des propos vis-à-vis de la
gauche c'était des propos d'adversaires
politiques de ce point de vue pour
terminer si bien que de discours est
encore tout chaud il ya une demi heure à
peine
est-ce que l'on peut envisager leaf
électorale marylise quoi oui alors c'est
difficile de l'empêcher aussi vite
ce qu'on peut dire sur les a priori je
dis bien a priori je crois que cibler
sur l'électorat de gauche qui est très
mobilisée depuis six mois je vois pas
des faits évidents bon en revanche on
peut imaginer qu'il puisse y avoir un
effet pour deux catégories de gens d'une
part oui d'une part pour ceux qui à
l'intérieur de la majorité était un peu
démobilisée
à cause des agressions interne de la
majorité alors cela évidemment ça ne
peut que les rasséréner attendu bon et
puis d'autre part pour ceux qui au fond
tiennent assez largement le résultat du
scrutin entre les mains aujourd'hui
c'est à dire en gros les 20% de français
qui dans tous les sondages n'ont pas
encore fait leur choix et il est évident
que cela il leur parlait les yeux dans
les yeux manifestement merci pour être
tout à fait complet avec événement
sachez que demain soir nous vous
présenterons comme nous l'avons faire
d'autres circonstances et je sais que ça
vous a plu
le regard de trois de nos cameramen sur
ce voyage en bourgogne regard sur les
coulisses un regard différent la
politique c'est aussi ça et puisque je
vous parle calendrier sachez que jean
lecanuet sera demain l'invité samedi et
demi demain donc à 12h30 que françois
mitterrand laurent l'occasion de donner
son sentiment sur le discours du chef de
l'état dimanche soir en direct dans le
journal de 20h et qu'enfin lundi soir à
21h30 dans quels cas vaches arbitral le
premier nos duels spécialistes hâtives
entre jean pierre soisson et robert
fabre la politique c'est aussi une
petite polémique entre la lettre de
l'unité l'organe du parti socialiste et
alain peyrefitte alain peyrefitte qui en
réponse à une question de patricia
charles holley avait justifié l'usagé de
la délation à propos de la terre en tint
bien sûr alain peyrefitte qui dit
aujourd'hui c'est de dénonciation que je
veux parler
la politique c'est encore ce premier
incident grave de la campagne
un incident qui n'a été révélé qu avec
une semaine de retard à saint dizier
dans la haute marne un colleur
d'affichés a blessé d'un coup de fusil
de chasse un jeune homme à sable passant
le color la fiche travailler pour le
député rpr sortant dans un premier temps
son groupe s'était heurté à des colleurs
d'affichés du psu couleurs la fiche a
donc était écroué lundi dernier la
politique étrangère maintenant est
d'abord ce qui se passe en tunisie car
ce qui se passe là bas est très grave
le ministre l'intérieur a annoncé que
près de 40 personnes avaient été tuées
hier à tunis au cours des affrontements
entre forces de l'ordre et manifestants
un bilan qui n'est que provisoire a dit
le ministre car des blessés très graves
se trouve encore dans les hôpitaux les
milieux syndicaux eux qui avait lancé le
mot d'ordre de grève générale du tout
est parti avance le chiffre d'une
centaine de morts et 10 que le
secrétaire général de l'union générale
les travailleurs tunisiens auraient été
placée en surveillance sur vie je crois
que nous avons au téléphone en direct
maintenant notre envoyé spécial type
rochot l'arrivée de l'armée dans les
rues auraient été étudiés aujourd'hui
seuls quelques échauffourées ont eu lieu
dans la banlieue de la capitale
les magasins avaient rouvert leurs
portes pour la plupart étaient quand
même la ville en état de siège qu'elle
aurait des parfums de fleurs et il ne
devrait plus rester en vigueur à partir
de 6 heures du soir en présence de
groupes le gouvernement a pourtant pris
un risque salut de tout couper un peu
plus de la centrale syndicale l'union
des travailleurs tunisiens qui
s'interrogeait en véritable mouvement
d'opposition
sa technique au parti unique la question
du camp de dadaab et les manitobains ont
été de l'avant prise à partie par le
gouvernement de monsieur miroirs et de
dépasser quand à beyrouth et à mika loi
dite de peur s'est engagé entre le
gouvernement et le cantal syndicale
l'atypique portugal confirmation de ce
que nous disions en début de semaine
trois centriste modéré font partie de
l'équipe de monsieur suarez qui peut
donc gouverner sans s'occuper de
l'attitude des communistes en argentine
ne me à l'intérieur admet l'existence de
près de 3500 prisonniers politiques
et puis en urss un groupe d'ouvriers et
de techniciens d'ingénieurs viennent
d'annoncer la création d'un syndicat
libre et ont demandé à l'organisation
internationale du travail de les
reconnaître
une audace qui peut coûter cher aux
auteurs de l'initiative vous le pensez
enfin au proche-orient et bien nous
sommes loin du tintamarre des dernières
semaines mais égyptiens israéliens
continuent à s'activer en coulisses pour
essayer de débloquer une situation
rendue difficile depuis le début de
l'année négociations plus discrète donc
loin des radios et les télévisions
visiblement d'un côté comme de l'autre
on souhaite que la porte ne soit pas
fermé écouter ce que nous a dit le
ministre égyptien des affaires à son
bazou une rupture parce que les
institutions qui ont été créés pour
pouvoir permettre les négociations de
continuer sont toujours là
d'abord la conférence le comité où la
commission préparatoire du coeur est
toujours là nous n'avons aucune
déclaration ni de la part des états unis
il n'a pas des nations unies de la part
d'israël
livre la part de l'egypte que cette
conférence a été aboli en second lieu
les deux commissions qui sont issus de
cette conférence la commission militaire
qui doit se réunir au caire et la
commission politique qui doit se réunir
au qui devait se réunir à jérusalem
continuer à exister
donc le cadre institutionnel qui permet
à la négociation de contenu est toujours
là ces négociations qui étaient
suspendues
je pense qu'une des grandes difficultés
des négociations c'est que cette
négociation ait lieu en même temps sur
le plan technique a maintenant sur le
plan de la mass media
ce qu'il faudrait essayer de faire c'est
de pouvoir négocier sans avoir à faire à
la mass médias essaient d'avoir des
négociations qui soit aussi discret que
possible et ce n'est qu'à partir de ce
moment que on pourra supporter des
difficultés qui en dans une grande
mesure a mené à cette suspension des
négociations
et si les négociations sur discrète ça
permet aussi à tous ceux qui sont contre
cette idée de négociation de dire que
vous préparez une paix séparée donc il
faut quand même aussi que l'on sache qui
mens pas question d'une paix séparée la
politique égyptienne est extrêmement
clair et déclarations du président
sadate sont extrêmement claires nous
luttons pour une paix totale par rapport
à toute la question du moyen-orient et
certainement pas une paix séparée pour
le sinaï
le président sadate a été à jérusalem
pour défendre le droit des palestiniens
le droit des syriens et le droit des
égyptiens et pas du tout pour une paix
séparée
vous avez parlé pendant 30 heures on a
fait le compte avec menahem begin sur le
plan humain vous le jugez comment je
pense que c'était exagéré de parler de
mais enfin je pense que il ya une
volonté sincère de la part de toutes les
personnes intéressées le tout les
négociateurs de trouver une solution à
cette crise je pense que cette volonté
est l'élément le plus important est dans
la note d'optimisme d'optimisme malgré
les grands des différences qui séparent
les points de vue des deux groupes de
négociateurs la hausse du prix des sens
maintenant prévue depuis longtemps
l'augmentation sera finalement moins
fortes qu'annoncé elle devrait augmenter
de 4 centimes le 1er février et 5
centimes pour le super les chiffres
exacts seront
arrêté lundi mais je crois que nous
sommes en mesure de vous les donner
définitivement les pétroliers ne sont
pas très content d'autant que le gas-oil
lui n'augmentera que de 3 centimes le
litre et le fioul domestique de 1 franc
60 l'hectolitre les pétroliers ne sont
pas très contents mais les consommateurs
le sont peut-être davantage la sphère en
plein maintenant je vais la voir vous
dire qu'il y a tout juste deux heures
les pousses du baron empain nous a
demandé à nous tous journalistes d'une
associée à son épreuve par notre
discrétion ça veut dire que pour elle et
là je la cite l'information ati ou
hasardeuse pourrait compromettre les
fragiles chances de survie du baron
empain
elle a bien dit fragile vous comprendrez
donc que nous respections son souhait
légitime s'il est une certitude c'est
bien que la rançon est énorme et c'est
le général du chalet qui serait chargée
de la négocier le général du chalet qui
était souvenez vous notre invité dans ce
journal quelques heures après l'annnonce
du rapt et là encore une information au
conditionnel et leurs mamans sont donc
la plus grosse jamais réalisée à ce jour
dans internet oui faisons le point si
vous le voulez en matière de rançon
depuis deux ans c'est pour un enfant
christophe mérieux enlevé à lyon en
décembre 75 qu'une équipe de kidnappeurs
a demandé la plus grosse rançon exigée
avant celle de l'affairé empain 20
millions de francs petites coupures et
en devises répartis dans sept sacs en
toile de 30 kg ces sept avaient été
déposés dans la cour d'une ferme les
ravisseurs dans leur précipitation on
oubliait plusieurs sacs contenant une
somme de 4 millions de francs le 31
décembre 1975 cet homme louis hazan pdg
de la société phonogrammes est enlevé en
pleine séance d'un conseil
d'administration à paris ses ravisseurs
réclament 15 millions de francs coupures
de 500 francs pour sa libération
la rançon doit être versée place de la
bastille à paris deux complices sont
arrêtés au moment de la remise des
billets louis hazan libéré et ses
ravisseurs inculpés le 4 février 76,10
todorov ce directeur adjoint de safran
s'est enlevé devant son domicile
parisien
la proximité est la police est à
proximité de la remise de la rançon et
les versets elle n'est pas récupérée par
les gangsters la première fois la
deuxième fois l'argent s'envole en
septembre 76 800 mille francs sont
réclamées contre la libération de
françois ferrié dans le
à cannes dans la villa du compositeur
francis lopez la rance en coupures de
100 francs devait être déposée dans un
cimetière elle n'a pas été versée le 13
avril 77 le kilo révelli beaumont pdg de
fiat france est enlevé à paris
la rançon fixé à 150 millions de francs
est ramenée à 10 millions par ses
ravisseurs
la plus grande partie versée sur un
compte numéroté en suisse et retrouver
l'autre partie livrée en petites
coupures à l'étranger par le fils du pdg
se volatilise en août de la même année
un banquier bernard mallet est kidnappé
au bois de boulogne vous allez la
personne d'arnaud un instant ce pont qui
est retrouvé peu après ses ravisseurs
n'ont pas eu le temps réclamé une rançon
septembre de la même année avec 10 triel
roland simon enlevé près de lyon
négocié lui même sa libération contre
deux millions et demi de francs en
billets usagés 200 francs et lundi
dernier à paris
le baron empain est enlevé et ses
ravisseurs demandent vous le savez 100
millions de francs eh bien voyez vous
depuis deux ans dont 60 millions de
francs étaient versés à des ravisseurs
l'occasion de l'enlèvement de ces sept
pdg et de cette somme la moitié
seulement a été récupéré alors france
accord les d'une façon générale quels
moyens on les ravisseurs pour essayer
d'obtenir une rançon
alors il ya plusieurs façons de verser
une rançon en billets en or en bijoux ou
par le transfert de banque à banque
alors prenons la première solution je
voulais les billets 10 milliards de
centimes en coupures de 500 francs
cela représente un volume d'un demi
mètre cube et ça pèse environ 250 kg ce
n'est pas facile à transporter ce n'est
pas discret et s'il ya les policiers qui
sont aux trousses des ravisseurs
ils ont des chances de se faire pincer à
ce moment là en or cette rançon
représenterait un poids de 3 tonnes les
lingots peuvent porter des points sont
discrets et demi avant la livraison et
les truands peuvent se faire repérer à
la revente donc c'est une mauvaise
solution pour eux aussi les bijoux il
faut des bijoux de grande valeur pour
atteindre cette somme de 10 milliards de
centimes
il faut s'y connaître être un expert ne
pas se faire donner un bouchon de carafe
par exemple la place d'un diamant et il
faut transformer ses bijoux pour le
revendre donc il faut passer par des
herbes un des intermédiaires c'est
encore une bien mauvaise solution reste
les bons anonymes et des comptes
numérotés les truies on n'aime pas le
paiement par bons anonymes pour des
problèmes de partage ils ne préfèrent
ils préfèrent l'argent liquide
alors parfois alors les comptes
numérotés s ce sont les comptes anonymes
vous savez sur les banques suisses mais
en matière criminelle les suisses lève
le secret bancaire
donc les solutions il y en a beaucoup
elles ne sont pas ça et si les
ravisseurs de monsieur enfin réussissent
à empocher cette rançon
ils ont prouvé qu'ils étaient très bien
organisés et je crois que c'est le cas
il faut dire aussi que un moment on a
cru repérer yves mon petit à paris
c'était dans le métro et pendant près
d'une heure le trafic du rer a était
interrompue mais la trace du tueur de
sucy-en-brie n'a pas été retrouvé
simon weintrob a été suivie s'est
suicidé cette nuit c'est un imprésario
très connu dans les milieux du show
business expert en peinture et
producteur de films il avait souhaité
acheter le paquebot france à l'automne
il n'y a pas d'explication à son geste
la vie existe peut-être sur la planète
mars la nasa se mord les doigts
aujourd'hui elle est peut être passé à
côté d'une grande découverte et six sur
terre qu'est venue la surprise dans un
endroit des plus reculés l'antarctique
alors qu'en jeu clair vous allez nous
expliquer tout ça oui alors la vie
existe sur l'antarctique vous voyez ici
par exemple quelques man show un manchot
empereur film et pas de la base
française à terre adélice en année mais
elle est concentrée sur les rives du
continent antarctique qui est énorme
quand on pénètre à l'intérieur à des
centaines de kilomètres de la mer là où
il ya des croates gigantesque y
apparaissent il n'y a plus rien de
vivant ou du moins le croyait ton
jusqu'à ces derniers jours
en fait les savants américains en
trouver de la vie ont trouvé des
bactéries des algues microscopiques et
des champignons minuscule dans des
endroits il n'y avait même pas d'eau des
crevasses comme ceux ci mais elle
n'était pas ni à l'extérieur ni dans la
glace comme on l'avait trouvé avant elle
était à l'intérieur de rochers du rocher
un peu transparent comme du quartz voyez
il ya quelques millimètres simplement de
la surface alors imaginez que la sonde
viking au lieu de ramasser du tralala
vais casser des cailloux on aurait
peut-être trouvé la vie mais alors
restons dans les glaces georges leclercq
vous les peurs un petit peu
c'était mardi soir je crois en nous
parlant de la chute du satellite
soviétique qui contenait de l'uranium
or la chute dans le grand nord du canada
ont le voilà ici aujourd'hui les experts
américains et canadiens ont un petit peu
balayer toute cette zone a lorsqu'il ya
finalement danger de radioactivité oui
alors imaginons imaginons bien que les
avions américains canadiens et repérer
ici un morceau du satellite cosmos 954
un morceau radioactifs voyez cette
partie de réacteurs radioactives sur la
neige dégageant du rayonnement donc de
la chaleur va faire fondre le sol gelé
elle va faire fondre la neige ici cette
neige va se transformer en eau chaude
radioactifs qui va s'infiltrer dans le
sol à travers le sol gelé et si elle
touche une eau souterraine cette eau
souterraine peut contaminer des plans
des animaux des poissons et des hommes
là ça serait très grave vous imaginez
c'est le cas ou pas pour l'instant rien
ne prouve que la source détectés par les
avions américains ou canadiens soit
réellement un morceau de satellite cosmo
soit 154 voilà le score maintenant une
victoire française qui me ravit c'est
celle d'eric tabarly sur pen duick 6 qui
avec son équipage est arrivé hier le
premier à rio à l'issue de la 3e étape
de la course autour du monde 31 jours de
navigation c'est je crois un temps
record un temps record certes mais qui
risque fort de ne jamais être
officialisée car une menace de
disqualification pèse fortement sur le
bateau français en effet les règles
interdisent l'usagé comme l'est d'un
matériau aussi dense que les l'uranium
appauvri placé dans l'acquis une peine 8
tabarly proteste de son innocence
déclarant que la fédération française
avait assuré qu'il ne courait aucun
risque en construisant soap and 8
tabarly alors va-t-il s'arrêter là et
renoncer à poursuivre la course
un jury international va rendre son
verdict de la dépendra la décision du
plus prestigieux des concurrents en ski
la skieuse française danielle de bernard
victime ce matin d'une chute pendant son
entraînement elle souffre d'une fracture
du péroné et ne participera pas aux
championnats du monde à garmisch
partenkirchen
et puis jean pierre nicolas sur porsche
a remporté le 36e rallye de monte carlo
sa prudence et sa régularité ont été
récompensés dans une épreuve où les
conditions météorologiques
on était cette année déterminante succès
personnel encore plus importante pour
jean pierre nicolas que d'avoir damé le
pion à toutes les équipes du sinn il ne
faut pas obliger ou oubliées par dans
nos louanges l'est les deuxième et
troisième places des petites aires 5
pour un coup d'essai de la régie
bourrier c'était un coup de maître
voilà je vais faire avant de passer à la
météo un petit point avec noël mamère
sur les dernières informations et sur
les suites éventuelles du discours de
verdun sur le doubs
et bien c'est une réaction de monsieur
chirac qui est sous forme de nos
commentaires le président de la
république lui avait fait parvenir le
texte de son discours sur le bon choix
de la france et monsieur chirac n'a
voulu faire aucun commentaire sur ce
discours le temps demain donc comme
promis des pluies abondantes sur l'est
du pays et sur les régions
méditerranéennes ailleurs alternance
d'éclaircies de fortes averses il
neigera en montagne à partir de 1000 m
des vents forts dans l'intérieur et sur
les côtes de l'atlantique et de la
manche
peu de changements ce qui concerne les
températures avant de nous quitter et
bien je vais saluer la naissance d'un de
nos confrères voter du monde un beau
titre et une belle édition des deux
premiers numéros de cet hebdomadaire
sont consacrés vous le voyez à la grèce
et aux pays bas
un petit rappel votre prochain
rendez-vous avec l'actualité et à 22h45
c'est le dernier journal de patrick
lecocq tout de suite avant le thé les
clubs voilà je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée
je retrouverai dans une petite semaine
pour soir à bientôt